Sometimes I like to pretend
that I’m King James.
Blessed by the gods to choose my army,
my Lord Commander
and my home
But alas, I am not
I am Ser MarShon Brooks
A journeyman sellsword, who, not long ago,
was fighting in the distant lands of Chai'Nos,
spending years reassembling
what remained of my shattered spirit
only to land a seat
on the dreary benches of Memphis.
But fate is a curious thing
For yesterday,
House Suns requested MY services and offered
REAL assets in return
Ser Trevor Ariza AND picks!
Seems I shall finally prove to everyone
that I AM a knight worthy of minutes.
And what I once feared was my twilight
was in fact,
my dawn.
Welcome to House Suns
Thank you
Ser MarShon Brooks at your service
Wait. MarShon Brooks?
Yes...at your—
OK, we traded for Dillon Brooks
You wha—oh, um…
Dammit, they sent the wrong Br--
House Grizzlies sent the wrong Brooks
Are you bloody serious?
Oh, how the fickle tides of fate recede
as quickly as they crash upon my shores.
And though my sand castles may wither and wash
the deft hands of hope must
always be there to rebuild them.
I return to Memphis with fresh perspective,
renewed spirit
Dearest Jennifer,
I have received your raven,
and I beseech you understand.
I am trying
I tryeth every day
to bring you the ring you so desire…
Watch it. Hey, hey.
Look who we blocked coming down the lane
Well, look who it is!
The Boogie Knight himself
They say our bigs can’t defend
Please! I’ve got a torn Achilles
Oh, OK
Last I saw this lot,
you all were getting swept away
faster than a harassment case at House Mavericks.
Oh please, Boogie
regale us with the tales of
your extensive tournament experience.
Better none than yours
Don’t let him get in your head
Aw...
Good on you all for giving Jimmer another shot
What? No. I’m Nik—
Wait
I’m not going to fall for your hurtful tricks anymore!
You see, it seems the tables have turned!
Unlike you, I have two good Achilles AND friends
We got your back, Nik!
How do you like my sauce now?
Bitch
What a fellowship you all have
Almost makes up for the lack of rings
The Lord of Light...
Hearted Locker Room Chemistry
smiles upon our Brotherhood.
Who smiles upon you, Boogie?
You’ve got no rings and no friends
And which of those can you offer me?
Friends
I’d prefer rings
Well then join us! And together
we shall make it past the second round.
Whoa, whoa
I don’t want this guy here
He’s like, uh, mess with our flow
you know what I mean?
We have like, uh, good vibes and also
like, um, we have same agent
and he says it might affect my minutes.
Doesn’t matter
It’s water under the Bay Bridge
I’m signing with House Warriors
What? No, you can’t—
They’re like an All-Star House
That’s not fair!
That’ll ruin the Realm!
He’s full of it
Everybody knows House Warriors is over the gold cap
They can’t afford you!
No, it’s probably mid-level exception
-Yeah, it’s a mid-level exception
-Yeah, you’ve got the mid-level taxpayers
Oh right, right. The mid-level exception...
I of course know what that is
and fully understand it.
My mind is a buzzin’
For I heard a hot take.
Seems big Boogie Cousins
Turned into a SNAKE!
He rides to the Oak Lands
Where there’s rings all around.
Give his headband a rebrand
As a ring-chaser’s crown.
Oh yes! I love Four Bar Fridays!
Boogie
Dame
The only thing more hopeless than
this brotherhood is your bard career.
-Hey now
-Watch your tongue, Boogie!
You know, I expect you to be a bastard
but a coward too?
I’d rather die than share the court with Curry!
Um…
No, sorry—I mean the good—
I mean Steph
And the rest of those serpents.
Dame, we’ve got no chance!
We had no chance
But we do now
The Lord of Light-Hearted Chemistry is very powerful
To the humble, He giveth…
But to the greedy,
He taketh away.
The Warriors’ defeat can only come from within
No House can bear the likes of Draymond, KD
AND Cousins.
Their golden cup runneth over with assholes
Let him go
Hope you enjoy the regular season
you f--kin’ losers!
I hope you get the f--king eighth seed
so I can see your faces when we sweep you again!
I’ll crush you like I crush my Lord Commanders!
Does he know the way out of here?
He’ll get himself ejected eventually
My mind is a buzzin’
For I heard a hot take.
Seems big Boogie Cousins
Turned into a SNAKE!
He rides to the Oak Lands
Where there’s rings all around.
Give his headband a rebrand
As a ring-chaser’s crown
A raven has brought us
some news that is good.
House Blazers acquired the knight Rodney Hood
My Rip City brethren, rejoice and give cheer
Except for Nik Stauskas,
you’re now a Cavalier.
Wait, what?
Bye, Nik!
Good luck in Cleveland, Nik!
If you enjoy Game of Zones, please consider subscribing
It lets us know you support the show,
and we can notify you when new episodes come out.
Have you subscribed, Markelle?
No
I tried to subscribe, but I missed